Hey there.
This is Chris Abraham and this is the Chris Abraham Show.
I am frustrated because I can't find my digital recorder that I used yesterday for season 11 episode 1 of the podcast.
So now I am using the Samsung recorder on my Samsung Android S22.
Ultra or whatever it's called, which I love very much, but we'll see how well it does.
I'm assuming it'll work even when the screen goes off.
So I'm having some trust issues, but I thought I would do another recording right away.
I was thinking about everything that's in the news with regards to all kinds of allegations and victim blaming and all these other things that are currently happening.
And I thought I would address something that I find very interesting without being that controversial, although I'm sure that I'm always going to put my foot in my mouth.
But that thing is something that I see among leftists, and I don't think it's a good idea.
And there's an assumption
that if you throw yourself full-bodied and with full passion at someone who isn't your intimate, it is their responsibility to treat you kindly and with kid gloves.
So for example, if you are mostly peaceful, protesting at a mostly peaceful protest,
People are surprised when they throw themselves at law enforcement, throw themselves at police, throw themselves at riot response controllers, throw themselves at SWAT, throw themselves at ICE and INS, ICE and INS.
And then they're surprised when they lose their eye.
to a non-lethal anti-riot dispersion bullet or round.
Or they end up having to be intubated because their body responded badly to pepper spray or any kind of agent in the air to disperse crowds.
Or when your wife
is shot to death and the first thing you say is, why are you using real bullets?
I see this all over the place and it's just not an ethos that I have ever enjoyed even when I was a much more kind of liberal leftist young man.
And I guess it might be being an only child growing up in Hawaii, I don't know.
But
I don't feel like anybody is entitled, no, forget entitled.
I don't believe, I never believe unless I know someone and actually trust them, I don't believe that the world owes me a trust fall.
If I fall backwards, the kind of grace and the kind of assumptions that one must have in order to throw oneself
at armed people assuming that they will not shoot you in the face is amazing to me.
And how surprised people are when they get punched after using their words, especially after we've been trained for the last 20 years that words are violence.
And so responding to words with violence
is the next step of assuming that words are violence.
In a post, sticks and stones may break my bones, but words will never hurt me world.
So I'm always amazed how bold.
Now listen, if people threw themselves at pillboxes and if they threw themselves on top of grenades,
out of loyalty to their brother on their left and their sister on their right.
That's one thing.
Or if they have martyrdom in their heart or if they are willing to transcend pain or if they're willing to die for their struggle, then those are amazingly admirable things.
But if they throw themselves as if they're LARPing in an environment like a safe room,
Is that what they're called, safe rooms?
Whatever the room is where there's a puzzle, right?
Like if you go to some place like Disney, or if you go to some place like Six Flags, or if you go to some place like a carnival, or if you go to a museum, or if you go to an animal park, or to a zoo, or to any place, there's an expectation in a litigious world
that your experience will be maximized for safety and enjoyment.
And that's not how the real world works.
The real world is pretty janky.
And you can't...
you can't behave in a certain way and not expect the ego of whomever you're squaring up to not be so challenged that he or she might be willing to punch you right in the glasses that you think would protect you because only bullies punch kids in glasses.
No matter
what kind of protected class you are, no matter what kind of protected species are, even in the wilderness, if a protected polar bear, which is extremely rare and protected, charges you, can empty an entire shotgun full of slugs into the polar bear.
So when it comes to life and death, when it comes to feeling
and I'm not saying everything's noble.
No way.
I'm saying that First Amendment is not a force field against the Second Amendment.
In other words, there is no force field.
And the feeling that you can't do anything to me because I have my First Amendment right, or you can't make me move because I'm in a public space and I can audit you with video to prove my First Amendment right, or anything, squaring up with a line of men who are visibly carrying M4 carbines, are visibly carrying
Glock 17s are visibly carrying a non-lethal 12-gauge shotgun, are literally carrying an orange taser and have electrical gloves on.
You can't assume that someone who's just being paid a salary or a wage and who is not willing to die for their country
Because don't forget, police officers and federal agents are just government employees, one at the state or city level and one at the federal level.
They do not receive the same kind of bona fides and the same kind of admiration and the same kind of award ceremonies that someone like a CIA operative or a
a JSOC operator or even an army ranger or even a boot straight out of camp who is infantry on the field.
That is fighting for your country.
That's fighting for America.
But if you are just a cop, you're going to end the threat and you're going to have more
I don't know, kinship with your fellow officers than you are with the community at large.
And so there's been an infinite number of times when people want to throw out red cards when it comes to, like, I wrote an entire article in my awful substack about
how the more risky behaviors you do, the more bullets you put into your Russian roulette revolver.
Now let me explain what Russian roulette is.
Let's assume that it's a six round revolver pistol.
And the idea is you put one bullet in there and then you spin it.
And every time you spin it, you have one out of 6, a one out of 6 chance of
having the round end up in the chamber so that when you fire it you shoot yourself in the head.
Now it doesn't stack on itself every time it's the same likelihood of it happening based on some you know theories of how hard you spin and if you spin the same time every time and how
how much friction there is or isn't with regards to the cylinder, etc.
But my theory is the more risk behaviors that you add to your engagement with law enforcement or with your opponent in the streets or even with someone on the street who is not your friend, the more friction that you create with regards to your engagement with them and the more in danger
they feel and the closer they are to the line where they feel justified or they feel like their police union representative and the team of lawyers could justify this behavior and based on
I guess optics and everything else, but you kind of put too much of that into the mind of someone who is the kind of C student who would become a copper, right?
Detectives may be B students, ICE agents, C or D students, right?
So, and you have the kind of person, it's obviously
a predisposed cast of characters who would become an ICE agent or an INS agent or a police officer or a detective or whatever.
You're probably not going to get a Maoist to join the police corps.
You're probably not going to get a DSA member
to do anything with regards to being a copper to being an agent unless it is a journalist citizen journalist who is joining ice in order to do to write an expose I'm sure there's I'm sure that one-third of all ice agents are liberals who are trying to write an expose on what being an ice agent is like that is very that is very postmodern
So if you train someone and then you recruit them from the kind of people who might have had fights or might go to the roadhouse or might be happy responding to insult with a punch and you try your very best to deburr them, they're also human.
They also have cortisol
cortisone, cortisol.
They also have adrenaline.
And everybody out there is, in one way or another, a scared six-year-old little boy or little girl.
So there's an ethos in America that I said in yesterday's podcast, which is better to be judged by 12 of your peers than be carried
by six of your kin, which is to, it's better to, quote Reacher, it's better to be, it's better to serve retribution first.
In other words, you shouldn't wait until you're hit before you respond.
And even if there was never any intent by, let's say, Ms.
Good to ever run over an ICE agent
or a federal agent, that person has their own trauma that you don't know their story.
If you fall back in a trust fall and you end up dealing with someone who doesn't like touching people or is hyper afraid of disease, or I even think that Donald Trump doesn't like to touch people because of his
fear of ick, then you throw yourself against someone who you have zero experience with, you have zero knowledge with, and so forth.
And the world is not ephemeral.
We live in a post-9-11, post-patriotic world where there are panopticons, where there is ubiquitous CCTV, where people can know you from a gate,
And who knows, we might even have AI agents in people's ears now so that when they see someone in a heads-up display, very soon, if not now, you look at someone, it decides whether or not they have a history of activism, a history of violence, a history of being on the street.
At some point, you're going to have the equivalent of an assistant
at a cocktail party who comes up to you and lets you know what the name is of the man walking up to you and what the name of his wife is and what school his children are going to and so forth and so on.
And like I said, it is not ephemeral, which is to say if you are an activist or a punk or a thief or antisocial or rude or mean,
or not even respectful to the police and you live in a small town or even a small city because strangely enough, even in a city of 9 million people, a very small percentage is always responsible for most of the crime.
So you will become someone of note.
You will develop a reputation not only in the street but in the police station and
people are going to start to conspire to remove your piece from the board, to remove you from the battlefield.
Whether that means lock up or making sure that your criminal overlord thinks you're a snitch and takes you out or find an excuse to, I don't know,
do something to pursue you and make sure you wreck your own car.
I mean, there's any number of ways someone can kind of plan your demise if you seem to be getting away with things and the person decides that you're just trouble.
It's a common thing.
People do it in jobs all the time.
People take each other out in the dating sphere.
people completely torch someone else's reputation in order to clear the field for themselves.
I guarantee you that if you are a repeat thorn in a law enforcement agent's side, he is going to conspire to take you out, to do the equivalent of taking you out in football
and soccer, where they go ahead and they knock you in the knee, they give you an extra big tackle, and they take you off the board.
If you think that ICE agents and INS agents and SWAT responders and Capitol Hill police and DC cops and Secret Service people
are not intentionally trying to take trouble off the board even before protests happen or accidentally on purpose during protests, you are probably like me and have aphantasia and SDAM.
And aphantasia is the inability to visualize in my mind's eye, and SDAM is a real problem with episodic memory.
I know that there are things I've done
but I really kind of have a lossy understanding.
It's more like checking off bucket lists, but not checking off each time you've done something, every time you've done something repeatedly in your bucket list, you kind of only remember one time of doing anything.
And it has to be kind of notable.
And it doesn't hurt that if you're, it doesn't hurt if you
compulsively take notes and record things and take photos and support social media and that kind of deal.
So yeah, so people can hold grudges in the same way that you can hold grudges interpersonally.
Don't forget, it's not like the staff of Disney, where no matter how much you pester them,
the staff member cannot break character.
You have to realize that behind the samurai, the samurai drag of the ice agent who is dressed basically like Delta Force, right?
He's basically dressed like Delta Force.
He's in a jeans, he's in a button down.
He's got a big belt buckle on.
He's got a big old belt with a Batman belt with his weapons and his cuffs and his spare magazines.
And he's got a giant plate carrier on his chest with a plate that can stop a 7.62 by 51 round.
I guess that's what the NATO round is.
And he's got his cool glasses and he's got his cool baseball cap and he's doing his best to emulate his favorite operator.
And yeah, he's living his larp.
He's living his best larp in the same way that you're living your best larp.
And he's saving America with as much ferocity as you're saving America.
And he's making the world safer for his children in the same way that you're making the world safer for your children.
And he is fighting fascism with as much fervor as you're fighting fascism, except he sees that internationalist globalist collectivism communism is the worst kind of fascism to him.
Whereas, what is it called?
Terminate with extreme prejudice, is that what it's called?
Is sort of his way of doing it, which is you, the squeaky wheel, the squeaky wheel doesn't get the grease, the squeaky wheel goes to jail or gets deported or whatever.
And in the ice, in the INS person's mind, which is why there are so many black and brown people who are in ice, they very much have the same feeling that Cesar Chavez, Cesar Chavez had before he was muckraked.
which is to say he believed that the only way that Chicano and Latino Americans and black Americans will be able to live into the future outside of professional degrees is by making it impossible for people who are here illegally to undercut the price of field workers and to undercut the price of
union negotiations and collective bargaining.
So the reason why so many Latino, this is not race driven.
This is fairness driven.
And fairness comes in both sides.
Fairness says, I am a member of this club America with full standing, senior standing.
I'm a citizen.
I pay dues.
And so I'm entitled
to a country that does not have freeloaders.
And the anti-ICE, I can't tell where they're from because all the liberals that I know in Arlington are complaining about they can't have their cheap services anymore because all the
undocumented people have been scared off.
So now it's impossible to find anybody to do drywalling.
It's impossible to find anybody to fix their roof.
It's impossible to find someone to shovel their driveway in the winter.
So when you become close to liberals, you find out that they want their cheap stuff.
And if their cheap stuff
is if they can get their cheap stuff back without sounding like an ******* and by making it sound like it's human rights and that it's social justice and that and oh my god what if we say there's no there's nobody's illegal on stolen land do you think that'll fly?
Oh totally that'll totally fly and so I don't know it's true
It's true, if you import everything from China, you will always undercut the price of everything else and things will become cheaper.
If you undercut the cost of hiring humans by hiring illegals, then it'll collapse the entire economy and people who are here legally will not want those jobs.
The argument is we don't, for whatever reason,
this argument seems to be okay, which is, these furners love taking crappy jobs of killing chickens and picking cotton.
We just can't give them away to black and brown folk who are Americans.
Black and brown folk and blue-collar Americans, they don't want this kind of work.
So we need to give the work that nobody wants to do to the most garbage people who are happy for crumbs.
Is that what you're saying?
It sounds like it.
I've argued that I think that anybody who migrates, emigrates, or even sneaks across the Rio Grande and settles here illegally are some of the bravest people you've ever met in the world.
tearing yourself away from your homeland, tearing yourself away from the square mile within which your family lives.
It's not as much of A struggle anymore because I'll tell you, every single person on the planet has a full-time internet connection to the person they love no matter where it is around the world.
Like you literally can pay $20
for unlimited internet and you can have FaceTime with your beloved 24 hours a day if you're that inclined.
So it's not like back when I did my year abroad and the only way I could contact my family was with letters and once a week a phone card to them from the public telephone booth.
near the guard house at University of East Anglia.
No, now you have full-time connectivity with them.
You can chat with them all day.
You can be on Telegram, you can be on Signal, you can be on FaceTime, you can be on Zoom.
Everybody in the building who is from elsewhere who works here and even people who live here, I swear to God that you
There's a 50% chance that they are on a FaceTime call with someone at home in Arlington or in Fairfax or in the DMV.
But it's as likely that the person they're talking to is all the way down in Guatemala City or in
Costa Rica, which is fine.
I think it's awesome.
I think that there are jobs people don't want to do and I believe that there is an important market force.
But you have to realize that the people who are getting screwed by this also have votes.
And there are more people
who want a well-paying union job than there are people who have a law degree and practice law or entertainment law or are an actor or an actress or a politician or a social media influencer, right?
So you need to balance the fact that you get cheap **** from China and you get cheap service from undocumented workers, but at whose expense
And at some point, those folks are going to realize that they have a certain amount of agency in our system and that the moment prices come up, which I think is one of the genius things that Trump is doing, he's letting people know that they can't live on third world economies anymore and that they have to find a way to earn more money.
And I think that Donald Trump might be a secret
union guy.
I don't know.
Like it's really difficult to understand.
He is what they say in Catholicism.
He is a buffet Catholic.
He is a salad bar Catholic, right?
He is a salad bar Republican.
He is a buffet Republican, which is to say, he is the epitome of Rhino.
Republican in name only.
I mean, the only reason that MAGA exists is because of all the populace who are against neocons and neolibs like me.
The only reason I've ever voted for Trump is because I vote for the person who is anti-neolib and anti-neocon.
So I hate John McCain.
and I hate Lindsey Graham and I hate on the other hand I hate Hillary Clinton and I hate Samantha Power and I hate Ted Cruz
Right.
So it's very interesting to see how all of this shakes out.
I mean, I hate I hate Joe Biden because of how he behaved in the 90s and in the 80s.
And I'll never forgive him for the crime bill stuff.
And I'll never I'll never
forgive Hillary for the crime bill stuff in the 90s.
And they were monsters.
They were neo-lib monsters.
And yeah, so back to the topic of today's podcast, which is the whole entire concept of throwing yourself into the great unknown, throwing yourself into the abyss, so to speak, with the complete belief
Not only that your own packed, your own packed parachute will open, but that I don't know if you've seen on TikTok or YouTube, there's this thing where a bunch of
parachutist jump out of a plane and then someone jumps out without a parachute and
the conceit is that all of the people with the parachutes can find a way of attaching themselves to the person without the parachute, locking into them, and then opening up their parachute and safely delivering the person without a parachute to the ground.
I feel like that is modern protest.
You throw yourself
at a throng of people who you believe in any way are there to keep you safe.
And I hear that word all the time.
I mean, Mendami, Mendami is going through a lot of hell right now because he tweeted about how he mourned the thousands of people who died on October 7th.
And now Free Free Palestine is attacking him and saying he's a betrayer.
And so he's damned if he does and damned if he doesn't.
And a woman who was showing cleavage and had these bright white sunglasses on who was being interviewed said that Mandami promised that he would keep us safe, promised that everything would be safe, promised that he would take care of us.
I mean, how crazy is that to think that a politician, I mean, everybody knows that the way to tell whether a lawyer and a politician are lying is that their lips move.
This idea of self-infantilization, this concept of, I mean, I remember how much eye-rolling Democrats would make anytime right-wing people would talk about the nanny state.
And I think that's what the DSA wants.
That's what everybody wants.
They talk about the government as if it's their daddy or their mommy or their nanny or even worse, their substitute teacher or their choir master or anybody that if the moment they don't get their way,
They will cry rape or they will cry diddling or they will cry impropriety.
And as long as they've got full coercion, they're extremely happy at their position of power, which is to say, you're my ***** now.
I'm the boss of you.
do what I say.
And it doesn't always work that way.
Verbal orders aren't a guarantee of compliance.
I've had people screeching in my face and I just sat there just waiting for them to escalate to violence so that I would have an opportunity to respond the only way I knew how.
But yeah, some people will literally almost touch your nose with their nose screeching in your face.
You will feel spittle on you.
And
completely vulnerable, no defensive weapons, no offensive weapons, no arms up, completely within the distance of being able to hit them with your forehead and completely take them down.
And yet you remain restrained.
But that expectation, I mean, I'm completely well brought up and my mom brought up a gentleman.
So it's kind of a different thing with regards to me.
Really, I have to know that someone is about to escalate to violence before I completely execute a bum rush and try to take them out before they even have an opportunity to know that the fight starts.
But I will never respond to words with violence.
because sticks and stones may break my bones, but words will never hurt me.
And I'm a free speech absolutist.
I'm a free speech absolutist, which is to say in America, being an ******* isn't a crime and it's not illegal.
So that is what I'm saying.
I'm saying that if you throw yourself at a 250 pound guy that is covered in weapons,
then don't be surprised if you do not survive the day or if you end up in the hospital or if you end up losing an eye or if you end up with a record or if you end up whatever.
There's an infinite number of outcomes that are probably very different from the day that you projected for yourself with regards to the noble thing that you're doing, which is fighting
Hitler, literally orange Hitler, literally orange Nazi, literally brown shirts, literally fascists, literally Nazis.
And you had this vision, but don't forget, thousands and thousands and thousands of...
Hey Siri, how many people died during the French resistance?
Estimates of the casualties among the resistance are made harder by the dispersion of movements at least until D-Day, but credible estimates start from 8,000 dead in action, 25,000 shot and several 10s of thousands deported.
This answer is from Wikipedia.
Hey Siri, how many people were killed during the Spanish Civil War?
Estimates of the death toll vary.
Historian Paul Preston estimates the minimum number of those executed by the rebels as 130,000, while Antony Beaver places the figure much higher at an estimated 200,000 dead.
This answer is from Wikipedia.
All right, so, hey Siri, how many people die from protesting around the world every year?
Determining the exact number of protest-related deaths worldwide each year is challenging due to inconsistent reporting and varying definitions.
However, significant incidents have been documented.
In 2019, 212 environmental activists were killed worldwide.
Protesters not in Iran.
I'm talking about protesters in Western countries.
Okay, I found this on the web.
Hey, Siri, how many people, how many protesters in Western countries have been killed and injured?
Here's a long answer from ChatGPT.
There is no single comprehensive global database for protester deaths and injuries in Western countries.
But available studies and reports offer some perspective.
In the United States, for example, dozens of deaths have been linked to protests in 2020, including incidents during Black Lives Matter demonstrations and counter-protests.
Many of these involved shootings by other civilians or police, and hundreds were injured by crowd control measures like rubber bullets and tear gas.
In Europe, fatalities from protests are rare but do occur, usually during violent clashes or due to police actions.
Injuries, especially from riot control measures, are more common, often numbering in the hundreds during large demonstrations, such as the French Yellow Vest protests between 2018 to 2020, which saw several deaths and thousands injured over time.
Overall, in Western democracies,
Protester fatalities remain relatively low compared to authoritarian crackdowns, but injuries are frequent during large or confrontational events.
Hey Siri, how many people die in Western governments from authoritarian crackdowns?
In modern Western democracies, deaths from outright authoritarian-style crackdowns are extremely rare.
Western governments generally rely on legal policing methods, and large-scale lethal force against civilians is uncommon.
When fatalities occur, they are usually isolated incidents during protests or law enforcement encounters, rather than systemic crackdowns.
By contrast, mass lethal crackdowns, like those seen in Iran, Myanmar, or Syria, are not characteristic of Western nations.
Annual fatalities from government repression in Western countries typically range from zero to a handful, far below the thousands, sometimes recorded in authoritarian contexts.
That was from ChatGPT.
Hey Siri, how many people have died or been injured through American authoritarian crackdowns?
Here's a long answer from ChatGPT.
In the United States there have been protest-related deaths and injuries, but large-scale authoritarian crackdowns with mass fatalities are extremely rare.
Historical examples include civil rights era, 1960s.
Several dozen protesters and activists were killed over years of confrontations with police and segregationist violence Kent State, 1970.
National Guard troops shot and killed four students during an anti-Vietnam War protest, injuring 9 2020 protests.
During the George Floyd and Black Lives Matter protests, dozens of fatalities were linked to demonstrations nationwide, although most deaths were isolated incidents and not part of a coordinated mass crackdown.
Thousands were injured, including from tear gas, rubber bullets, and physical confrontations.
Overall, deaths from US government crackdowns remain in the dozens over decades, not the thousands seen in authoritarian regimes, while injuries during major protest waves can number in the low thousands per year.
Hey Siri, I thought Donald Trump was an authoritarian.
Donald Trump has often been described by critics as having authoritarian tendencies because of his confrontations with democratic institutions, media, and political norms.
However, under his presidency, the U.S.
government did not carry out large-scale, systematic, lethal crackdowns like those seen in true authoritarian regimes.
While his rhetoric was at times combative, and federal forces were deployed to some protests in 2020.
The number of protester deaths remained limited and no sustained mass killings occurred.
That was from ChatGPT.
Fascinating.
Anyway, guys, this was a ramble.
This was a rant.
I was just thinking about people throwing themselves into situations.
I was thinking a little bit of the Cornell 7 and
I was in a fraternity.
I was in Phi Kappa Psi.
And I think Phi Kappa Psi had some controversies, DC Alpha in GW.
I was a founding brother, a founding father at DC Alpha.
And it was great.
I loved it.
I didn't understand why anybody would want to become a Phi Kappa Psi little sister.
I don't even know what a little sister was.
I mean, they were the friends of the fraternity.
Oh, and don't forget that if you, I know you weren't in a fraternity if you call it a frat because you're drummed into as a plebe that
You never call a fraternity a frat in the same way that you never call your country a ****.
So that's part of what you're told in addition to learning the Greek alphabet.
And the high, high, high, Phi Kappa Psi, live ever, die never, Phi Kappa Psi.
And Letterman and more, you have to know your founding fathers.
Anyway, I remember that to this date and I don't remember anything.
But as a person who was in a fraternity, and this was in the, in the late 80s, so it was an entirely different world, we thinks.
But, and we didn't, and we were still a charter.
We weren't
We weren't a, so we were just starting out.
So things had, we didn't have a house or anything.
But I don't know why anybody would go to a frat party thinking that it was a safe environment.
I mean, I guess after you get to know brothers and you get to know them, but like seduction is coercion, I'm being told.
And I thought that we were in a post-seduction society, but everything lures with sweetness and color, right?
Everything lures with sweetness and color.
Flowers lure with color, fruit lures with sweetness.
And so I don't think that any kind of house party or any kind of fraternity party
or any kind of environment where it is being put together to lure women to come party with all the beer and all the alcohol and all the attention you could ever want.
I mean, it feels like you're entering into a den of thieves.
But I believe that I had a girlfriend and she
would tell me how the world should work.
And she was 5 feet tall and she was petite and she was beautiful and she had a gorgeous little figure.
And she would constantly throw herself into situations that would turn out very poorly for her, including sexual assault, including rape, including debasement, including having videos of sex being recorded.
Like
And she constantly told me that's not the way the world should work.
It shouldn't be like that.
I shouldn't be treated that way.
That situation shouldn't be dangerous.
That person told me, come stay at my room.
And when I stayed at his hotel room,
He expected that we would have sex and so I just sort of did it because it would be less awkward.
And the entire time I would hear these stories, I tried to detach myself, but all I felt was my heart crying, my heart being sad.
And also doing the same thing over and over and over again, expecting a different outcome is a sign of insanity.
So this was a broken record and it's another example of the world should be this way so I will engage I will engage a wild animal because
animals aren't mean, animals are children of God.
Or, oh my God, well, Mike is really cool.
I'm sure everything that they say about fraternities have been overblown.
Or, I'm at an Ivy League school, how bad could fraternities be?
Or, I really like this guy and I will do anything to get him.
And I will get anything to have him.
And even if he doesn't want to be my boyfriend, I will collect his scalp.
I will do anything to collect his scalp.
In the same way that I had a girlfriend who her entire goal was to have had slept with all the top nerds at the top level in nerd society.
And she had a list of the nerdiest, most accomplished in technology, the internet computing
computer science, engineering, she had a list in the same way that someone else might have a list of stars that they want to sleep with in Hollywood or rock stars that you want to sleep with in Cleveland, because Cleveland rocks.
She had a list of the biggest nerds and the biggest legal nerds and the biggest engineering nerds and the biggest venture capitalist nerds and they didn't have to be pretty.
They just had to be super smart.
And I guarantee you she had great success.
She was really beautiful and very elegant and so smart.
But that was a goal she had sexually.
And so people will put themselves in a very humiliating spot in order to get what they desire.
Yes, mistress, no mistress, yes mistress.
And so, I mean, I can't be angry at someone for following their kink.
But what do you think the outcome will be of this behavior?
I mean, and how do you think, what is that saying?
Let me see if I can get it.
Hey, Siri.
What is the biblical, is it Psalms that says protect your heart?
The verse you're thinking of is from Proverbs, not Psalms.
Proverbs chapter 4 verse 23 NIV.
Above all else, guard your heart for everything you do flows from it.
And I think that's what happens when people feel scorned or spurned or it doesn't turn out the way it should.
And I think that I had just shared online that there's a term.
Let me see.
Hey, Siri, what is the word musturbation?
M-U-S-T-U-R-B-Bation.
It's a must M-U-S-T-U-R-B-A-T-I-O-N.
What is musturbation?
I don't know how to respond to that.
Anyway, it doesn't matter.
Musturbation is this term that is apparently kind of a fashionable term in the sociological world that says that you have an internal belief that no matter what you believe it should be enacted in the world.
and you should be able to have a consensual threesome with two men and have it not be weird and then not have them brag about it afterwards and shame and humiliate you to their friends.
If you go in and want to have a threesome, it will be in the lockbox and you all throw away the keys and the boys won't just go away and tell their friends about what they did.
There's this musturbation, is this idea of self-pleasure that things that should happen in the world must happen in the world, and then you're completely blindsided when the most obvious stereotypical, most anticipatable, most obvious, most cliche
most completely, my God, really thing happens.
And then you're completely blindsided with it.
You feel completely astonished.
You are verklempt, you are spitting mad, and you end up completely hurt, ruined, destroyed, and your reputation is toast.
I like to avoid situations like that.
Maybe it makes me less brave and less
makes me more risk averse.
But shame and humiliation are things that people can really avoid by listening in many cases to the wisdom of their elders and their colleagues and wise books and philosophy and history and even page 3 or even every single TV show.
Every single TV show tells you that every action has a direct and opposite reaction and many of the time your ability and willingness to throw your trust at someone you don't know results in the sexual crime unit or a crime unit in general.
And I'm always amazed at the kind of trust that people have for people they don't know.
or people that they would do anything, they would sacrifice anything to have, to do, to be with.
And I understand passion, I understand desire, I understand lust, I understand hunger, and I understand, hey, that's no fair.
The world should be more fair.
But should isn't a word.
What is the thing that they say in 12 steps?
Stop shoulding all over me.
Anyway, on that note, this one was a rough one to do and a rough one to listen to, and I apologize for having to suffer through it.
I will get, oh, by the way, I listened to the second-half of the Oprah Winfrey podcast with Mr.
Tipping Point on there.
And the second-half of the podcast is hyper focused on black on black crime communities where there is, they don't talk about white communities at all.
They don't talk about white neighborhoods.
They don't talk about concealed carry states.
They don't talk about constitutional carry.
They don't talk about defending
households defending property.
They don't talk about anything like that.
They only talk about inner city crime.
And they only talk about black on black inner city crime.
So at the end of the day, the Oprah Winfrey Show podcast
ended up only focusing on a very small demographic in America that is very resistant to policing and would lose its, I mean, anybody who would put 17,000 police into Chicago is going to be primaried out to the very next election.
Like I said, if there's anybody in the entire country who hates cops more than Southerners,
It is black folk.
Black folk hate cops.
And if you introduce 17,000 cops into Los Angeles, 17,000 cops into Chicago, 17.
Hey, Siri, how many cops are there in New York City?
As of January 2024, the New York City Police Department, NYPD, had approximately 33,612 uniformed officers.
This number has decreased from a peak of about 40,540 officers in 2000.
Hey Siri, how many officers are there in Chicago?
With 13,292 police officers, the police officer to population ratio is approximately 1, 204.
Hey Siri, how many police officers are there in Los Angeles?
Hey Siri, how many police officers are there in San Francisco?
The police department of the city of San Francisco shall be composed of a day and night police consisting of 56 men, including a captain and assistant captain.
Hey Siri, how many total police officers are there in San Francisco, California?
As of 2022, the San Francisco Police Department has approximately 2,104 sworn officers.
This number is broken down into.
Hey Siri, how many police officers does
the District of Columbia have.
The Metropolitan Police Department of the District of Columbia, MPDC, more commonly known locally as the Metropolitan Police Department, MPD, and colloquially, DC Police, is the primary law enforcement agency for the District of Columbia in the United States.
With approximately 3,400 officers and 600 civilian staff,
It is the 6th largest municipal police department in the United States.
Hey Siri, how many police officers does Boston have?
The Boston Police Department has approximately 2,000 police officers.
Hey Siri, how many police officers does Miami have?
With 1,371 full-time sworn positions.
Hey Siri, how many police officers does Arlington County have?
As of March 2022, the Arlington County Police Department, ACPD, had an authorized strength of 376 officers.
However, due to attrition, retirements, and officers seeking other opportunities, only approximately 290 officers were functional and certified to provide solo law enforcement services.
That was from ChatGPT.
Hey Siri, how many police officers does Northern Virginia have?
Northern Virginia does not have a single regional police force, but rather multiple county and city departments.
Key agencies include Fairfax County, Arlington County, Alexandria, Loudoun County, and Prince William County.
Together, these departments employ several thousand officers.
Fairfax County alone has over 1,300 sworn officers, Arlington about 300, and Prince William and Lauden each have several.
Hey, serious stop.
You know, I really feel like Malcolm Gladwell was cherry-picking, comparing.
I mean, I guess the square kilometers of Los Angeles and Berlin are similar, but
Honestly, comparing 17,000 cops in Berlin to 8,800 cops in Los Angeles is kind of apples to oranges.
And the fact that there are upwards of 40,000 cops in New York City alone is notable.
I know that is the highest incidence of them all.
But I feel like Malcolm Gladwell's arguments with regards to over-policing or under-policing and all this other kind of stuff is extremely dispiriting.
And if I had known what a sneaky ******* he was, I would have not been so completely impressed by the tipping point because he definitely puts a finger on the balance and he definitely plays games with statistics.
in order to support his arguments.
And he was such a person I loved so much for so long that I defended him.
But he's indefensible.
He's shameless.
But he also doesn't want to be canceled.
So on that note, hey Siri, what is the quote with regards to statistics
There's damn statistics.
Here's an answer from Kittle Co and Wikipedia.
Hey Siri, can you read the quote?
Here's what I found.
Hey Siri, can you read me the quote about damn statistics?
Here's an answer from Kittle Co.
I'll read it.
The saying lies, damn lies, and statistics is a famous phrase.
It talks about how numbers and facts, statistics can be used to make weak arguments sound strong.
People also use this phrase when they don't trust the numbers someone else uses to prove their point.
All right, everybody, don't forget to join, subscribe, follow, give me 5 stars, give me a review.
You can listen to me anywhere.
I'm everywhere.
I just launched a new website dedicated to the podcast yesterday, the ChrisAbrahamShow.com.
I had Claude Code build it up for me, and it's magnificent.
And when I add this episode, it'll automatically add it to the app, which is based on GitHub page.
And
On that note, thank you for listening.
Thank you for listening this far.
Please share it with your friends, like and subscribe, and I will talk to you soon.
Mahalo nui loa, aloha kakou.